just before I get onto this sub conical
pendulum business I want you to comment
very briefly on this astronaut okay
so um I'm not gonna give a full
explanation I think the hardest time
about this for me when I was doing this
question was just to wrap my head around
like what on earth is going on and then
the maths kind of sorts itself like that
the manipulation the calculus sorts
itself out okay so here's the picture
just put your own put your pendulum down
in for employment okay here is um here's
a flight simulator okay what they've got
I think their picture says an astronauts
in a mechanical flight simulator moving
with uniform circular motion in a
vertical circle by the way um it's
really hard to do this like just with
words when they say vertical circle a
circle
obviously occupies a plane right so when
you say vertical it's just it's just an
axis right what they mean is ah is the
circle is the plane facing up down like
this or is it like that right there is
still like if I show you this plane
clearly there's a horizontal - making
here like this right there okay but when
they say vertical what they mean is like
you know standing up I said that's why
I've got this picture so you've got the
astronaut right and the astronaut is is
going around and round and around like
so and they say let's read the rest of
the words what angular velocity is
required to cause the astronaut to feel
weightless during the instant at the top
of the vertical circle okay now this
whole a whole bunch of series of things
that are confusing about this okay for
starters what does weightless even mean
like what's going on here they they
realize that's a bit confusing so they
clue you in they say at the top of the
circle so he is
here's the astronaut at the top of the
circle and this ain't ya at this
particular point they are not
experiencing any weight the question is
why
okay and then then that sort of guide to
the mathematics now for starters we can
say look obviously wherever this some
astronaut is on this flight simulator on
this circle they are all always
experiencing for weight force that is
putting downwards because they're on
your right so it's like here it's going
down that way he are it's going right
down along the radius that's really
important I think it's really really
important any other thing I want you to
note is that because they are like
experiencing this downwards right to be
weightless to be weightless is to not
feel that anymore okay
to not experience this force okay now
let's just think about this right um if
you were weightless you're so I put an
object I put it in the air right it's
suspended somewhere right and it didn't
have any weight how much weight force is
it going to experience zero right well I
should say if as no mass therefore
experience the rivers so it's going to
stay still here does that make sense it
why would why is that why is it not
moving which Lord is talking about this
is this first law it's experiencing no
forces so it's stationary it could be
moving in uniform straight-line motion
as well but at the moment it's just
staying okay so the corollary of that
thinking about that from the other way
around is if therefore I want to
experience myself being weightless not
having any weight not having the weight
force pulling me in a particular
direction right therefore what I need is
to have a net force is zero right that's
what I want okay
if net force is zero then I'm not going
to feel like I have weight okay now look
at the diagram with my green screen go
okay look at my diagram you got weight
force going this way so therefore in why
don't you counteract this for us there
must be a force going off in the
direction of the normal right
but this is confusing to me because if
there's one thing we know about uniform
circular motion it's that when you're
moving in a circle there's a force
acting on you in which direction towards
the center so how why is this going off
in this direction maybe you want to
label some things for me right this is
the this is the weight force so it's
empty right mg going that way and then
you've got this guy now why is that
there I will tell you why then this is
all about the hardest part of this is
it's about what the astronaut is
experiencing there is a force going out
in that direction but only because it's
about the astronauts experience not
because of what's physically going on
okay physically the only force that some
only two forces that have been
experienced here are the weight force
and physically there is a force going
towards the center wherever they are
because they're attached to this flight
simulator right so that's why they don't
fly off into you know off into the space
right actually because their honor okay
ah but I want you to remember when we
were going to uniform circular motion we
worked out we resolved all the
horizontal vertical forces and we saw
okay this is the normal force and then
we said hey what about this guy what
about along the tangent okay what force
is being experienced there zero zero
force okay
this tangent is important because the
tangent is the astronauts point of view
right it's what the astronauts
experiencing they're always there along
that tension you know experiencing
reality along this tangent right it's
like here's forward for me and that
keeps on moving in moving in moving
so therefore what the what the
astronauts going to experience he is
remember he's going around here and on
from the perspective of the tangent he's
not moving from the perspective of the
tangent right so therefore if he's not
moving there must be balanced forces
right there must be net force zero
so what this means is advances force
towards the center the centripetal force
but there's this and it's actually
called it's literally called a
fictitious force this is the actual
technical name it's not really a force
it's a force that the astronaut
experiences because from his point of
view he's not moving it's an inertial
frame of reference okay
so seeing as he feels like he's not
moving right he experiences a force that
way which is why if you're on a roller
coaster you feel like you're being
thrown out towards the edge of the thing
you're not the roller coaster coaster is
holding you in that's why you're not
actually flying off okay but you feel a
force and that's what that feeling of
weightless comes from this fictitious
force if it exactly balances with the
weight force then they cancel out and
therefore you there's a bit force of
zero now because this some force to what
the center is called a centripetal force
I think it's a team might be named this
central force is going towards the
center it's the real force but this
fictitious force RP what's fell is
called a centrifugal force okay it's not
actually a force in the way that gravity
is a force but it's what you think
spirits it's what clothes in a washing
machine experience when they get flung
towards the outside okay so this force
is what balances with the weight force
okay and so you've got to work out the
speed that will make these exactly the
same in terms of gravity okay